une nuit il ya eu laurier goudreau julie
le breton incarne dans la tragédie
la nuit ou laurier gaudreault s'est
réveillé une thanatologues en exil
depuis 11 ans et elle est de retour dans
sa ville natale pour embaumer la
dépouille de sa mère
rapidement une sombre histoire de viol
refait surface
ça parle de trahison
aussi et à quel point c'est les
trahisons les mensonges les sacrés
peuvent avoir des dommages collatéraux
et dévastateur ce texte est du michel
marc bouchard tout craché dans ce
suspense où le spectateur est sur le qui
vive
il y a des effluves de ses autres pièces
donc tom à la ferme qui a d'ailleurs été
adapté au cinéma par xavier dolan mais
je poursuis tel un artiste un peintre la
même palette avec le teint dont l'angle
change alors c'est sûr que j'ai comme
l'impression qu'ils ont déjà mec qui te
répète ne sera fait tant mieux si je
suis fidèle et pour être fidèle à
l'oeuvre de michel marc bouchard
le metteur en scène serge denoncourt a
délibérément réunit des comédiens qui
ont souvent travaillé ensemble j'aime
beaucoup mon les métaphores de charge
pour les acteurs et c'est des mercedes
et des roses run sap et ça me permet à
moi de conduire très smoot et de donner
un petit coup de volant et on s'en va à
droite et tout le monde suit c'est sûr
que la base est déjà là on sait qu'on
s'entend bien on connaît l'autre dans le
travail
j'ai travaillé avec eric j'ai travaillé
avec julie j'ai travaillé avec qui mme
despatie et les présentations de base
sont pas des chemins et le soc a déjà
été fait en plus tout de suite aller à
l'essentiel
ce que j'ai vu ce soir là c'était plus
troublant qui lasse s'offre en f
à la fois divertissement est sujet à
réflexion l'ennemi ou laurier gaudreault
s'est réveillée est un cocktail explosif
d'émotion où les apparences sont parfois
trompeuses
[Musique]
ici louis fait dépouiller mais
radio-canada moria
[Musique]